hey how many records
uh nev that we never heard because there
was this um
rumored sequel to the uh
good music album that was supposed to
come out i heard one song
called trash bags that lifted played me
uh
that was like almost like a mercy part
too but i'm sure there was something i
feel like i do remember that trash bag
yeah it had the whole lineup yeah they
had pushed they had everybody on it
i remember pushing pusha t had a line it
was like body bags i need my money in
body but it was crazy but nonetheless
um how many records did you guys like
did you have that were supposed to come
out that ended up not everything god
that's the thing
bro even with the whole watch the throne
[ __ ]
um we have made other records
in person like you know i'm saying like
[ __ ] in paris was a beat i just
emailed
the the records we was making while we
was in the studio was
uh totally different they didn't even
see the light of day they never
i thought them songs was going on watch
the throne like [ __ ] was hype on them
didn't make it then this beat i just
randomly emailed ended up being like
damn that the biggest song on the album
so
oh no no no not damn near it's literally
the biggest song of the
world yo do you remember like the first
time you saw the
reaction in the club to that song hell
yeah for sure
because the reaction in the club to that
record was like i said being
really on that i was just hype i would
be hyped to make a song and then go to
[ __ ] hide and
or wherever it was cracking at the time
and just watching
that was one of them few records we had
them greystone nights
you could bring that record back like
eight times back to back to back like
those happen like once every like 10
years bro yeah
like that record i remember you could
play that [ __ ] seven times in a row in
the club and that's the show in at the
concert
oh they did do it at the concert
actually that [ __ ] like 13 times i know
i saw them in vegas and they were i
think they did yeah
i think you were there in vegas too were
you were you at the video uh
not for the throne show i was there for
a whole year in l.a though
i was in l.a yeah paris new york yo that
shit's crazy man